that Monday when we met when we were
supposed to get with Elon when we landed
we were told that Steve's channel was
permanently banned and it just kind of
sold sucked a soul out of all of us
Steve loves Elon and there was one time
he made just this joke video when
Bitcoin had crashed and you know it came
out that like Elon sold all his Bitcoin
and Bitcoin crashed and Steve like lost
a lot of money so he made an anti-elon
video Once that's a joke you know the
biggest problem Steve will do it has and
I think this is what's led to Steve's
termination of his YouTube is
all right guys bang bang I've got John
here with me uh I thought a great place
to start is last time we talked you were
doing nothing with happy Dad milk
anything uh you guys have absolutely
exploded onto the scene and what I think
is interesting is like there's a Content
story and then there's a business story
and everyone is very focused on the
content because that's what you can see
right yeah uh I care about the business
and uh when I see you or any of those
guys posting and you're going to like a
liquor store and there's literally a
line out the door around the block you
know there's cops there making sure that
everyone's like staying in line making
sure they're getting in people are
signing uh all of the alcohol like this
is a massive massive movement and a
business that you guys are building how
do you think about day one you walk in
you're like all right we have to build a
business here like what do you think is
the advantage that you have and how do
you think about which products to launch
and kind of like what to sequentially do
from a business perspective yeah
um well I always say this and this is
pretty much a no-brainer trainer and you
know but but it does come down to the
product being great at the end of the
day
um it's always got it always has to
start with that right and that's the
advice I'd have to give anybody it's
like no matter how big you are how many
followers you have or how many
connections you have with whatever
retailers or whatever it is your
product's not great like people are
gonna give
every product a chance once if it sucks
they won't come back we're going on to
two years of happy Dad now our rebuys
are absolutely insane we haven't
launched a new state in six or seven
months we're about to launch five new
ones in the next six weeks but we
haven't launched any and our sales are
still growing in the existing States
because they're rebuys and we haven't
even Revisited those stores yet so it's
really the product it has to start 100
with a product
um and then yeah then there's a lot of
others but why happy Dad right like what
like why is that the product that you
guys like we're gonna hang our hat on
this and we think this is the thing that
we can build a big business around
we want um you know the Seltzer business
has been growing over the last few years
um it's pretty much become a beer
replacement uh and happy Dad the way was
the The Branding the marketing or even
the type of can that we used was really
to Target the male audience when it
comes to Seltzer consumption almost
every single shelter you see right now
comes in the skinny can multiple colors
you know just going after
yeah and now you know and
our initial because and it wasn't
necessarily oh we need something for men
it was like our audience were men the
milk audiences men eighty percent plus
of the milk viewer
um across all socials are men so we said
all right what can we make for our
audience that will convert
um what's funny is like female is the
love happy Dad we could get into why
like you know it wasn't our Target but
you know I think because of the
flavoring and the amount of carbonation
I could get into that but you know
um and maybe even let you know that
we're launching happy mom but we'll talk
about that so because of that but um but
yeah I think um really happy Dad was we
want to go after the Seltzer Market it's
become
a pretty much a replacement to beer uh
for all different types of reasons from
The Taste to the calorie count carb
count now people are a lot more
conscious of their health right now
um you know I think a lot of different
reasons post pandemic realizing that
maybe the best
um you know solution to you know
something what happened with the
pandemic was actually your health versus
can't go down that rabbit hole of uh you
know don't say it but you know but but
Health at the end of the day you know um
health is wealth and um and I you know
and I think we all want to be healthy
now you know I think we've learned over
the last few years like you've got
Health as well and I think that the big
narrative was uh milk had these amazing
videos that were going super viral to
this big audience uh it reminded me a
lot of like the Barstool audience early
on when I was in college and uh in the
Northeast like you just knew they'd show
up for the Blackout Tour or whatever and
like people would show up right and
these guys seem to be able to say hey
I'm gonna be somewhere an audience
showed up right like they were willing
to go do that they also were buying a
lot of merch and so usually those two
you know data points tell you hey this
is a real audience it's really engaged
it really kind of subscribes to the
lifestyle and and the values and all
that type of stuff
um but they weren't monetizing any of
the content as far as I understand right
like there weren't a lot of brand Deals
they uh didn't have any ads from YouTube
or any of that stuff and it pretty much
was just like a merch business attached
to content is that like a fair uh way to
evaluate what they were doing before you
guys really got into a lot of the
consumer goods yeah well um merch was a
big part of their business because they
were demonetized from YouTube
um
during pandemic years during 2020
um they you know they were the ones that
weren't refusing to not go out and party
still and they were still having
Gatherings and filming The Gatherings
and and they were demonetized by YouTube
uh but milk was a pretty big
organization on the back end you know
there's a couple dozen employees so
um they had to figure out how to pay
bills and merch kind of became the pivot
and focus and um and you know we say to
this day is being demonstrate being de
monetized by YouTube ended up being one
of the biggest blessings because you
know the merch Revenue has been
30 40x what YouTube Revenue would ever
be from an ads inside and then on top of
that
Brands brands are extremely afraid to
work with creators they've always been
afraid
um you know
um just seeing what's happened over the
years with different creators which I've
never agreed on why everyone was so
angry at some of them you know and
trying to cancel everybody but the the
creators that have been canceled over
the years it's frightened
um
a lot of Brands and that's also become a
blessing in disguise because like brands
have always been afraid of milk
um and um or all types of creators but
specifically an elk so that's where
happy deaths come in he's like all right
do we go and do a super small deal with
Anheuser-Busch and try to explain
ourselves and then be limited on the
content be careful of the content or do
we make our own brand which
better decision yeah and now walk me
through operation one of the things that
a lot of folks in the business World a
lot of investors are waking up to is uh
these creator-led businesses basically
did the business Creation in Reverse
right usually you build a product then
you go find the customers nelk and many
others have basically found the
customers first and then they go in
there building the product but building
the product for many creators is
actually a really really hard thing to
do they don't have that skill set they
don't have the connections they don't
have the capital they don't know who
like am I going to have operate this
thing you obviously have been around for
a long time you've seen a lot of
different businesses
um and you have not only are you well
connected you guys have access to
Capital like you know I think a lot of
folks kind of say like oh John's there
like this has got a shot of actually
working from an operational standpoint
how did you think about operationalizing
it right like just you showing up you're
not going to do everything so like you
build out a whole team do you go and you
just like partner with somebody and it's
your brand with their operations like
how does that work
um you know the one thing I've always
been very good at is finding delegating
work and finding the best person and
being able to hire and fire a higher and
and find the best person for any
specific role so
um specifically with happy that
obviously there's so many different
sectors of our businesses there's
alcohol there's merch there's media with
our podcast but but on the Alcohol side
when the decision was made to make happy
Dad
um there's this family that I know the
butau family long time friends of mine
been in an alcohol business for many
years but decades I mean they're
the father Keith bhutaus you know
um you know they call him the Godfather
of the alcohol industry like so went to
straight to them and said Hey listen
um need to make an A plus product you
know I've got
the platform the milk boys we want to
make a Seltzer We Got The Branding we
got everything but we need the liquid to
be a plus and they're like say no more
and immediately start creating the
flavorings we did taste tests and you
know now that's one thing that I've been
really great at and then then now that's
the that's the beverage that's the
liquid now who gets final say on the
taste test
it's all of us there's a there's a group
like consensus there's a group of about
seven to ten of us and it has to be
unanimous
um if one person doesn't like it we go
back so it's no like not sorry Sam
we like it you don't or sorry Kyle or
sorry Joe butau it's everyone has to
okay I love it um that's why we go back
and forth so much if one person says I'm
not sure
we're going back so and I think that's
been part of the happy death success has
been that too um but then you know
there's that part there's the liquid
then there's
then there's a liquid and Manufacturing
right from cans to breweries
um it originally starts with flavoring
then breweries cans but then then now
it's got to leave the brewery it's got
to go
two different states every state we have
a different distributor so I had to find
someone to help me find the right
Distributors the right Partners a lot a
lot of states and alcohol are have
franchise loss meaning once you sign the
deal with that distributor you're in
with them for life crazy law by the way
that's crazy crazy obviously a free
market principle of course of course 100
euro laws you know so so anyway so now
we're like all right so if we're in with
these guys for life we got to be careful
because one is they've got to be great
they got to make us a priority uh they
can't have a product by a competitor
because we'll be bullied you know if
they carry like let's just say I don't
want to name any competitors but we all
know who the competitors are in the can
alcohol space uh you know if they say
like hey like these happy that guys you
better shove them out make you know like
they're going to listen to the bigger
guy of course
um but then also you know with
distribution you got to also say like
all right one day if the you know a
strategic partner wants to come into the
business do they like that distributor
because you're in with them for life so
you know there's all those pieces we had
to learn as well so I had to bring in
someone to help me learn that side of
yeah things so I did that that then that
happened and then then there is now the
retail sideers all right cool all right
we got a great product it's been shipped
out to the Distributors
um how do I get Krogers to care how do I
get Publix how do I get Walmart how do I
get 7-Eleven Circle K how do I get them
to care so that was you know so I was
able to go and pretty much help find
best people you know there's the point A
to Z is so long in alcohol but I was
that's that's something I've always been
great how much of the talent that you
ended up recruiting were you able to
just go to them early on and say hey
here's our idea here's you know the milk
boys here's Their audience size like get
on board versus you had to kind of get
things in motion and get some momentum
and then it was easier to convince you
know some of these a plus people to come
on I think I've been very lucky and I've
said this in a lot is um I've always had
this philosophy of um life is long not
life is short and I've built some really
great relationships in the last 20
something years that I've been in
business where
um when I make these phone calls almost
everyone kind of knows I'm a man of my
word and they'll give me a chance
whether it's pre-launch shortly post
launch whatever it is you know I could
with some of my friends I've been very
very very lucky with the friends and
partners that I have that you know I can
make calls and everyone's going to give
me a chance yeah why do you think that
is is it just that you've been doing it
a long time and you've been successful
and kind of always done what you said or
something else yeah yeah I don't I'm I'm
not a Bridge Burner yeah yeah that's not
that's not anything that I do is burn a
bridge I know and I'm still I'm old but
almost still still young you know I'm 43
years old I know when I'm 55 years old
I'm gonna need to call you for something
you know and I know when I'm 55 you're
gonna take my call or vice versa you're
gonna call me and I'm going to come
through for you you know we're going to
know each other in 12 years you know so
so that's why to me I'm almost thinking
my relationship with you or my
relationship with whomever your brother
anybody
you know we're still pretty young yeah I
mean people have a hard time thinking
five or ten years in advance let alone
if you're you know in your 20s yeah
right some of these guys the boot house
is 40 50 years from now the bhutau
family I met in
1999. I met the new bootel family 1999.
yeah I was 19 years old at the time
maybe 20
um 20 years old I think I was at a time
when I met them
um I mean I met them so long ago I was
actually with them when 9 11 happened we
were literally watching TV together like
that's how long ago I knew them so for
me to 20 years later yeah for 20 years
later I was like Hey listen I know you
guys are got all these partners and you
guys are doing these Tequilas and vodka
I think they were part of the Tito's
team and
um I forgot the name of the tequila but
a big tequila
um I actually had a business with them
we created an alcohol a long time ago
and the alcohol failed and you know many
know when if when a business fails
Partners usually hate each other and
don't ever want to talk to each other
again it's like we still love each other
and they still took my call this was 15
years ago we made that tequila That
Failed 15 years later they're still
taking my call so I think that's kind of
the lesson for anyone in business is
like don't burn a bridge life is long
life is not short you know when people
say life is short they're just like dude
get whatever it takes go burn that
bridge screw that person you you you you
I don't I don't agree with that yeah and
I think it's kind of proof now it's like
you know when Kyle or Steve or any of my
partners calls like hey can you help get
this can you help get this done it's
like
thing that you know I'm sure we'll talk
about it but even like getting Elon Musk
you know on how'd that happen dude
I asked him twice first time he said
maybe
second time he said sure but that's uh
email email them at the time and then
like hey then um then I followed the
second time was a text I was like yo you
said maybe you know like like what do
you say what do you say in the texture
are you hitting Elon with like a you up
text or are you just like very specific
hey we're gonna be in Austin here's the
date and time can you do it
um no he he said if you're in us or he
well
both try to be as specific as possible
but be short as well I know I only have
a few seconds of his time
um but when I had text when I texted him
the last time
um I said hey
I think this is a great weekend to do
this at the time the Twitter deal was
kind of pending I said I'll stay away
from any Twitter talk because there was
like that's Taco Twitter lawsuit and all
this stay away from all Twitter talk
um
I'll give you final approval on the
video
I actually think that this is something
that um many people who aren't in the
content creation business don't really
understand so journalists there's no
final approval right they're going to
write their story they're gonna do their
interview they're gonna uh kind of
produce whatever content they are and
they go out with it and they do their
best for the most part to try to be
accurate and try to get you know all the
different perspectives and and kind of
um I think most journalists are trying
to do the right thing uh but when there
is no final approval like it just goes
out and a friend of mine recently
somebody wrote a big article about them
and I texted him and he's like I'm happy
with how it turned out right and so it
was like kind of like you don't know
until it's out and he read it and he
liked it now in podcasts and YouTube and
all this stuff what I've noticed is
there are a lot of Business Leaders a
lot of
um uh investors those types of
individuals who are gravitating towards
podcasting and YouTube style content
because they do get to see it at the end
and I think that there's a difference
between like what some people would
refer to as like the gotcha journalism
right which is like hey I'm trying to
get you to say something that's
bombastic so then I can twist it or
whatever versus like we're going to talk
about things today that are like
non-controversial right and it's like I
want you to be able to feel comfortable
to talk right and vice versa when you
guys are doing those interviews but how
important do you think it is that you
say to a guy like Elon you get final
approval it's very it's very you know
it's what's crazy what you're saying is
it's very important because we offer it
to every single guest and what's crazy
is nobody's ever called us to take this
out right because I think they feel so
comfortable that they're just like not
on the spot and they're not overthinking
what they're saying because they're like
okay at the end day I'm gonna have final
approval yeah there wasn't a single
thing Eli I didn't he we didn't even
talk about it after we just went live I
think we went live like a two days later
like you never said hey I thought you
said final approval there was nothing
sometimes we'll ask someone at the end
like I remember we did David portno and
I text them I said hey anything that you
want to take it out of that he said no
um you know sometimes I'll follow up and
ask but almost never has anyone ever
told us even though we've offered it no
one said hey take that one part out or
whatever I always say that the people
who asked for a bunch of stuff to be
removed we've had I don't know maybe a
1200 episodes maybe like five or six
people who have been like you know
literally one person one time was like
here's the time stamps take out this to
this this whatever it's like those are
the episodes where you're like look it's
already trending where if you're that
worried about it you probably really
weren't saying things anyways that were
super super interesting and so uh the
more successful somebody is the less
likely I think they want to I can tell
you right now there'll be no no changes
required from this episode
there'll be none if I said something
wrong that's on me that's that's not
that's not your team's fault that's
that's my fault all right uh so you guys
do the Elon interview what is that like
I mean you guys are obviously you're all
in there I think that you and kind of
your background your relationship you've
known them right all this stuff is very
different than maybe like Kyle or any of
the other guys like
what are they like before Elon comes in
the room right what like what is that
whole process like well it was um
it was I think a little nerve-wracking
because it was one it was supposed to be
done the day before and there was some
kind of like some hiccups and some
issues with like different things that
it didn't happen so then the next day
actually I didn't get a hold of Elon
till like 3 P.M the next day so um
so there were you know we we had flown
out
um it was my brother's birthday the day
before so we had flown out and you know
spent a lot of money last second to fly
out and
I'm just sitting there
I took my wife with me at the time so
I'm just like I had like some like
emotional support because I was just
like I can't let these guys down like
the whole team flew to Austin because
the last message you were asking about
the last message with Elon was hey I'm
down to do it this weekend and
um I said where where are you gonna be
and he said Florida or Texas I was like
oh like
like which one like I don't even know
you go to Florida I've never heard of
Elon going to Florida I was like you
know coin flip yeah so I was like which
one and um
I said should we just book our
flights to Texas
and he just wrote back sure I was like
okay so then we just did that this was
on a Friday
I said hey we'll be there Monday
and he said okay some things happened
Monday couldn't happen
so then um I said hey let's do it
tomorrow he said message me in the
morning message him in the morning
didn't hear back till like 3 P.M and
then he just wrote me like see you at
9pm tonight
so 9 p.m on a Tuesday the world's
richest man is rolls what is it like in
a hotel room we got we had got a hotel
room like in downtown Austin yeah and so
he just rolls in and just sits down a
[__] podcast okay
it's always so fun to me right because
you you always remember like once you're
around these folks that like they are
humans right they put one pent leg on at
a time like all the normal [__] they
text right pulling up like whatever uh
but from afar right like he's dealing
with the Twitter stuff he's got somebody
tracking his like uh private plane he's
freaking out about right like yeah like
all this crazy stuff you got to deal
with when you're the world's richest man
in running all these companies and then
like you find time to you know yeah go
chilling he's the best man I after that
like he and I've always and I was going
back to another relationship I met him
in 2013. so this is now what we're
talking about is August of 2022. so it's
like nine years after like nine years of
me and him just kind of like just kind
of occasionally chat and ran into each
other a few different times
um
mutual friends birthdays uh
actually one time I was at a restaurant
he was there we get you know we're ran
into each other we were sitting next to
each other but uh uh you know we just
always kind of stayed in touch
um but after then like he and I really
stayed in touch like you know there's
like it's like kind of crazy now it's
like I talk to him weekly like really
yeah all day usually Twitter yeah
usually Twitter like giving them like
product tips uh creators like like I
really he really cares about the Creator
space and
um he really wants Twitter to be the
greatest platform for creators so he'll
he'll definitely call me on we'll talk
product a little bit
um he knows like my background was like
building the app 10 years ago with shots
but um but I think more is like creators
like you know creators of all different
worlds not just YouTubers and
influencers but like athletes and actors
and actresses and
um and musicians you know stuff like
that one of the things I saw that he was
talking about I don't know if they're
going to implement it or not that I
thought was a pretty interesting idea is
they're going to put ads potentially in
the comments and then the Creator who
creates the original post right could
get a share of uh the actual ads in uh
in the comments yeah yeah you know it
would be like the equivalent of YouTube
throwing up ads in the comment section
and then you get a share of it and I
just thought like okay whether that
works or not it's always unclear right
you get kind of tested in the look of
the data and they'll decide whether it's
worth shipping or not public man they're
thinking differently yeah right like
they're they're willing to test
something that model Works in taboo
right that model works on Snapchat does
that right now with creators they run
ads in between stories on snap and they
share that with creators and it's very
good money so this um you know obviously
Twitter doesn't have stories I do think
and I have to hold Elon a few times I do
think Twitter should bring back stories
like you know if you remember they had
fleets yep um just just like was like X
I mean even the name what's a flea isn't
that when you buy a bunch of cars like
but but you know just bring back Twitter
stories and just call it Twitter stories
but you know
um but yeah I mean now but the way
they're doing it because of the comment
section which is you know a lot of
people read on Twitter
um versus just viewing
um I think you'll get a lot a lot of
engaging people and I think you can sell
that engagement to advertisers as well I
mean putting the view count alone right
was a pretty big deal like it definitely
I think open people's eyes like hey
people may not be engaging but they're
here yeah they're watching right I
thought that was genius yeah I did too I
think I know there was a lot of backlash
in the beginning but I thought it was
genius I hope that feature is here to
stay um I think it's great I actually
messaged them that too I said hey I
think this is a future that should be
here to stay yeah
um who you guys trying to get on the
podcast that you haven't been able to
get yet is there like somebody who's
like on the full send podcast because we
have a few we have the pivot so on full
sense specifically
because most people would think Elon
would be like the top of the mountain
right but you guys already got him is
there anybody else that you guys are
like look who's on Elon we've got the
Trump's been on there
um you know he was on the podcast I
don't know the video didn't last yeah
yeah I think 48 hours or 24 hours
um did you know to get taken down
no no I don't think it would so that one
even after you guys recorded you thought
that it was going to be fine yeah but
someone from his team a good buddy of
mine who works for him said hey this is
going to be taken down pretty soon watch
and I said why he's like because read
all the comments they're all positive
about him and because it's positive it's
going to go down I was like
okay and then you read I mean even if
you read because we we weren't going
into that Trump I want to answer the
question about who because I love that
question
um but um
we weren't going into it as a political
yeah you know like we try to stay clear
politics as much as possible
um a lot of the podcasts I actually
helped write the questions so like some
of the questions were like what songs on
your playlist what do you listen to when
you're a shower like you know you know
even like joke I don't think they ever
asked this one but like what do you
think about the Kim at the time was
relevant Kim and Connie's situation and
like you know like just felt like dudes
hanging out that's that's what we wanted
and he is what regardless of your
politics yeah he is a master manipulator
of the media and he has hot takes and he
has posted frankly some of the most
viral content on the internet in the
last decade I mean I still tell people
like when he was president one of the
most ridiculous but hilarious things
that he did was when he was tweeting at
Kim Jong-un and called him low Rocket
Man
he's the funniest man like and you're
just like dude you're the president like
please don't start world war three but
also like okay you didn't start World
War Three like that shit's pretty funny
yeah right and the entertainment factor
is like off the charts and so yeah
the debates the debates in 2016 and the
ones again in 2020 like and so that's
what it felt like just great content it
felt like you guys were there hanging
out with him and firing questions that
he never gets asked right and like
I mean I want to almost go as far as to
say like it looked like everyone was
enjoying it like he was having fun and
then the guys were having fun too yeah
we had the best time and I'll be you
know again like I should try to steer
clear of politics but I could just say
one thing about him he was so cool to us
like he was so kind like even when the
cameras are off he was just like welcome
here I'm making sure we got everything
we needed and then we ran into him twice
since we ran into him at his golf course
in La
um and then we ran into him at a um at
the live golf tournament in New Jersey
um same thing like every time he's
giving us a hugs and like asking us how
we're doing he actually
um I saw him a couple months after I got
married in June and he said hey I heard
you got married congratulations and you
actually sent a letter to like uh me and
Renee and like congratulating us on our
wedding and like yeah just like you just
like that's why it's hard for me
to like just be around any negativity
but also like I'll be honest like I'm
also not a uh I'm not a Joe Biden hater
either like at the end of the day the
man's
the president of our country you know he
asked service the country for a long
time
um and I think you know
he was elected president and you know
his age might be his only one of maybe a
major flaw but like that's not his fault
like we still voted him hey you know so
it's like you know you know I think
there's a lot of people who wish that
they were uh operational at uh at his
age yeah right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I'm actually sometimes impressed I mean
sometimes it's funny he writes on these
clips where he's just like reading and
like completely like you know but it's
like you know what what can we do with
politics you know I I just laugh there's
nothing we can do there's nothing you
and I can do to change anything like you
know I mean like we could go and vote
and our vote counts but that's about all
we can do you know like you know so now
we're just gonna sit back and enjoy it I
think that's it it's great entertainment
everything in everything that is seen
through the portal of your phone or your
computer has become entertainment and
sometimes that's good sometimes that's
bad but like I think that gets lost a
lot of times because people take so much
so seriously but like if there's one
thing that we've learned is that if
you're entertaining and you can hold
people's attention you're charismatic or
whatever you win right you win in
politics when in business you win in all
these different facets and I think that
is one thing that uh the younger
generation has an advantage on is like
they grew up with the phone in their
hand yeah right like they understand
that in you know it's the life is a
movie right and that's how they live
their lives yeah yeah
um you were asking earlier about who on
full sent podcast
um
I think uh one of the things so had Elon
have had Trump
um I've had Dana White who I you know
admire Mike Tyson
um
I mean I mean you know Dave Portnoy
which I think is probably one of the
most underrated entrepreneurs of our
time
um but um I can't say anything nice
about Dave because in a recent episode I
called him a pioneer of the digital
media age and I'm just waiting for him
to find that clip and then go and uh and
celebrate so yeah he's incredible in
terms of what he's done I think people
don't uh give him the credit he deserves
for a 20-year run doing it too right
it's not like you just show up on the
scene for two years I think he's the um
I would put him in top five greatest
um
entrepreneur in the World of Sports you
know like when you're making that list
of like the greatest entrepreneurs in
the World of Sports and you take out all
the sport owners you know that Jerry
Jones is and Al Davis and all them take
all those guys out
um but on sport entrepreneurs like I
would put them in top five all the time
of our time of our time yeah yeah I
don't know who was doing stuff in the
70s and 80s but of our time yeah I would
say who else is up there Reuben Reuben
100 Ruben
um
um I mean just those two guys Dana White
right yeah Dana White yeah yeah there's
probably like five or six people you
could come up with that you're like man
they've built what is hundreds of
millions or billions of dollars of
Enterprise Value specifically the
intersection of media business whatever
and sports yeah and they've done it
really redefining what sport is or how
it's covered or you know whatever yeah
and like that is the definition of a
Pioneer right yeah yeah I would say Mark
Cuban too you know obviously he owns a
Mazda outside of Mavericks he's done
quite a bit as well but
um but yeah I think those you know were
guests going back I want to try to
answer that question again because I
think about it all the time who else and
what's the direction of the podcast
um I think
um different creators or celebrities or
whatever who um who actually have
products like I also think full send
podcasts could be a platform for someone
who's got their own happy Dad or
whatever and come and talk about the
business with the boys because that's
the one thing with Kyle especially who's
the main host of the podcast
it says podcast and um you know he
really understands he's very Hands-On
with the business of happy Dad so like
let's just say like I was just talking
to Kevin Hart's um partner in the
tequila and we were talking about how
how to get Kevin on and what would they
talk about you know Kevin doesn't really
know the elk boys all that well and you
know so
um that would not be a funny episode at
all yeah I know I know I can't wait you
know it's gonna be some one-liners in
that one but um I think um who's taller
yeah
but no I think um talking about like his
tequila you know and like the business
the stuff that we opened up this podcast
with and talking about is like the
business behind you know like his his
tequila um
I need to try it I haven't tried it yet
but everyone has talked about us tequila
let's talk about it's a 10 out of 10
product it's because it's on the higher
end of the tequila like he's not going
after like the lower lower end like it's
a higher price point tequila but um but
it's like you know we share Distributors
and our Distributors like when I just
randomly I'll ask him like how's Kevin
Hart's tequila like crushing it
absolutely crushing it so so
is it Crush I know it's not crushing
because of Kevin Hart he's got the right
Partners Now Kevin Hart's got a crazy
platform and like and what he's doing
it's helping but it starts with your
partners and like he went and he went
and found the right partner this guy
James who's awesome and then James went
and got the right
product made you know and then they went
and I know they the Distributors that
they use the same ones we use
great A Plus and and then now Kevin's
got this platform and now he's grinding
as well and all the time so it's like
you know there's so many different parts
to building a you know a Creator product
which what Kevin's tequila is I think
like getting guests like that to talk
about that like or another one that I
think is a very underrated business
because he has so much potential I was
actually talking to him this morning
about his David dobrik and his pizza
place you know one might look at it's
like wait it's just one location off
Sunset Boulevard yeah that location is
less than six months old like wait until
you see what he does with this over the
next few years the opportunities of
growing it into multiple cities may be
franchising it maybe you see the frozen
pizzas and Costco's you know I mean like
like David dobrik has a billion dollar
business right you know in his hands you
know yeah um what was fascinating to me
is that all of these Brands uh are the
equivalent of as a kid when we grew up
like Cece's Pizza nobody knew what the
hell CC's was right yeah uh it was just
like you went to a place you liked it
you kept coming back but now what ends
up happening is somebody like a David
Dober can open a pizza place and he's
done the marketing for years he's
already built the fan base he's done all
this stuff and it is the like athlete
endorsement type model now it shows
these people are realizing like own the
business right and it then begs the
question like
the milk boys are they creators or the
entrepreneurs right Kevin Hart is he a
movie star is he comedian is he a
entrepreneur like I was an entrepreneur
I think that they all fall under that
entrepreneurs that just happen to create
you know different than you and I yeah I
mean like you know we were businessmen
but we also know how to create but in
different ways you know we know how to
go on podcasts and speak well they know
how to create Kevin Hart knows how to
create in front of a live audience
telling jokes or no boys know how to
create great content that'll go viral on
YouTube and the internet you know just
in different ways but how do you think
about how big happy Dad is like in terms
of are there numbers that you guys have
shared publicly in terms of like how big
that business actually is
it's very big but what's crazy is um you
know when I say we're two years old
um we right now we're only as of
now in March 2023 we're in 16 states
only and in those 16 States we have less
than 10 penetration we're not in every
single store yet in those 16 States
um but when you look at the Nielsen
charts that's public to anyone who wants
to go look or subscribe what however way
you want to get access to Nielsen is
um we're moving up on the charts in so
many different
um parts of America you know we uh you
know we're
we're top 10 everywhere that were
available but in some regions and some
stores we're a top three you know top
three alcohol Brands top three Seltzer
so white Claw is number one buy a
landslide truly's number two and three
four five have always been kind of a
battle between vizzy but light Seltzer
um depending on your region there's a
lot of local ones like in Southern
California there's one called Ashland
um you know there's never been a solid
number three and we've in a lot of
territories we've taken that number
three and we've kind of locked uh
topachiko as it was a big one that's
actually was number three in a lot of
slots um it's owned by Coca-Cola
um
but we've in a lot of areas we've locked
in that number three so now because like
white Cloud's got number one locked for
now for now yeah for now yeah but there
are also got many years ahead of us I
mean why class I would say like six
years old uh maybe a little bit older um
then truly's got number two locked you
know but we were we wanted to lock
number three now we're locking number
three in a lot of regions so so that's
you know that's only in the 16 States uh
we're launching five more States we're
launching
um
we're launching Canada
um Canada is a big market for our
um our content consumption and and then
also like what we're also now looking at
is like uh different audiences at
different sectors
of consumers uh we know
we know if you're 25 to 30 years old
you've heard of happy Dad you've tried
happy Dad if it's available in your
state uh but now we're looking at a male
if you're 25 to 30 year old male uh now
we're looking at okay how do we hit
female Market how do we hit
the Latino Market how do we hit
the black market like how do we hit you
know these other markets I'll just take
all the demographics whether it's uh
race gender sex whatever you can do and
just cut through every single one of
them yeah how do we keep penetrating all
these different things so I'll give an
example of the female Market is uh one
is um it's not a day where a different
female is coming up to me is like well
why happy Dad why aren't you doing Happy
mom I've been hearing that for almost
two years you know so great idea yeah
great idea so we're doing happy mom
um and it'll be a similar type of
product and just different brands the
same product just different flavor and
we said okay so instead of 10 men taste
testing the flavors which is what we've
been doing last couple years with our
existing flavors let's get 10 females
women who work for us women within our
world in the industry uh my wife she
came in yeah Renee's one so pressure
yeah ten of them tenable Jesus I mean
they all had to be honest but uh if
anyone's gonna be honest it's gonna be
her but the 10 of them came together and
they came up with the flavor together so
so you know so like all right cool so
the the Brandy's there the flavor's
there 10 women love this flavor and
we're gonna that's gonna be the first
flavor is Happy mall so now we're going
after the female market and how do you
think about the audience being 80 90
male right whatever it is uh being able
to crack into that other side of maybe
now it's not just the content drives it
right like is it now something where a
happy Dad can like be bigger than milk
can it Escape you know kind of uh being
hey there's this group on YouTube who
has a big audience and like that's why
happy Dad is successful and eventually
people just say like no happy Dad is
like a successful Seltzer that uh
survives on its own even if milk never
uploaded another video hey guys I hope
that you're enjoying this conversation
as you probably realize we don't run any
ads on this show that's right all the
other podcasts all the other YouTube
shows that you watch they have
advertisers we don't have any direct
relationships with advertisers and we
simply create this because we enjoy
doing it now that we do that so we have
a team and if you'd like to support us
one way you can do that is to go
subscribe to the pomp letter it's a
daily letter that I write to about 235
000 people about my personal opinion on
financial markets business technology
and Bitcoin just go to pompletter.com
and you can sign up there I'd love to
have you join us and it's a great easy
way to support the work that the team
and I are doing on a daily basis all
right let's get back into this
conversation
um I think it's become bigger than no
can I'll give you a couple reasons why I
know just from experience
um this one's a small one but this one
happened but this has happened once with
one person so I can't really tell but I
have another example
um Kyle who's the creator of the nelk
boys
um he um main base of milk was him and
Steve but Kyle was on a flight he's
wearing a happy Dad hoodie got next to
him sitting next to him says hey
love your hoodie man I love happy Dad
because I was like oh cool he's like
thank you [__] I'm sitting next to a fan
this is gonna be a brutal flight yeah
yeah so the guy's just talking about
happy Dad this and that and at the end
of the flight
um a guy just like hey what's your name
he's like Kyle I'm so so Kyle's like wow
this guy doesn't even know who I am like
he had no idea the guy who Kyle was he
was talking about happy Dad and you know
I was talking about why he likes happy
that and this and that and
I don't know if Kyle ever to revealed
who he was yeah he's just like this was
crazy like this guy had no idea so
that's one but uh this is this this
other one is a bigger example is um
we did a test run in Costco okay so
Costco Northern California they said we
want to test happy then
um we want to test it in nine locations
and uh usually a product when you want
to get into Costco you'll make a bigger
product because Costco always likes the
lowest price so you want you want to
give them but they look at per unit
price so that's why most people make
like larger Club packages
um for Costco so you get maximum dollar
but at a cheaper price price visual
price point we weren't ready to do that
we only have a 12 pack available so we
we're like all right well you're just
gonna have to sell the 12 pack for now
we don't it's going to take us some time
to make a 24 or 36 pack I think we've
decided to make a 24 now but um
so we give them
12 um the 12 packs they tested nine
stores in Northern California
the product got shipped out earlier than
we knew so it was it got it got
delivered to the Costco stores a whole
week before we had this whole marketing
plan in place basically just and like
the marketing plan is like we're going
to tell people to go buy it we're going
to show up yeah yeah we're gonna do all
this stuff we'll sell out for sure we
got to impress Costco we got to show
them how fast we move
um the product got there a whole week
before we didn't know and people are
messaging us like hey just saw you at
Costco and I'm like what do you mean
like we're not supposed to be there
until next week Thursday but it was a
whole week the Thursday before
calling some of our partners they're
like
yeah um so by the time we got some
answers
um it was like now Monday by the time we
got answers
and I'm like well we gotta like
implement this thing I don't want Costco
to think we're a flop right you're sold
out all nine Costco's so what we we
never promote it look at our socials we
never promoted available on Costco no
one posted on social media and one thing
like I mentioned a few minutes ago our
audience is 25 year olds and up 25 30
year olds in Northern California
that is not Northern California is not a
big market for us and 25 year olds
aren't really going to Costco to shop
yep yep so it's not our even audience
how much of this is like um uh Prime uh
I don't know if the numbers leaked or
somebody reported them but the prime
drink
um I think they did like 250 million
dollars last year in uh revenue and uh
I've talked to a couple of friends who
have kids that are you know kind of like
eight to maybe 15 years old no like my
kid can't find it my kid you know if
there's a gas station locally that has
it like they all spread the word very
quickly and they go and they pick it up
and some of them are even reselling it
at school for a a premium and like all
this kind of stuff right like how much
of that is baked into what you guys have
done with happy Dad when I see people
you know in a line down the street and
it's like look we want to sell out but
like there is this scarcity element of
it that drives people to go to run over
to Costco and buy at buy it out because
it's not widely available in Northern
California yeah yeah yeah well we are
available in Northern California the
cost one was a whole different audience
that gave this gave happy Dad a try
whether it was older guys it's so so
I'd love to talk about Prime in a second
what you were talking about their
numbers but uh but
with happy Dad so the the neighborhood I
live in is all you're not going to find
an adult under under the age of 35 it's
you but it's like younger families 35 to
50 year olds live in my neighborhood uh
I've made a mandate like every we have
three grocery stores in my neighborhood
and we have like five different bars and
I've told our team Hey listen like
everywhere in my city and I live in a
smaller City 20 000 people
um every location that sells alcohol in
my city you gotta do me a favor make
sure we're stocked up like I gotta see
it like I don't want to go to my
Albertsons or my stator brothers or even
my Selma's Pizza the pizza place or
board and Brew my sandwich place and not
see happy Dad so they've made it they're
like all right and literally I said it
because me but also like I think this
audience is 35 year old 50 year old men
you know what are they're they're all
dads you know I mean like they see a
product called happy Dad and I think
that's what happened in Costco like
happy Dad
you know I'm here I'm here to buy a
bunch of tri-tip like I'm you know I'm
I'm I'm a happy Dad
um my wife let me out of the house
so I think people were you know the
marketing of that is now getting the 35
year old to 50 year old men whether
they're people living in my neighborhood
or going to cost the Costco Shoppers uh
but the products would be great because
somebody went back and bought it again
you know like somebody went and said hey
let me give this a try you know you know
it's about 12 of them you know you took
them out in a day or two and went back
that Sunday or Monday and bought more so
so the rebuys are really important going
back to what we opened up and talked
about was the products got to be great
yeah
um
but yeah so I think that's so the
scarcity of it I think maybe helped a
little bit in the very beginning but now
it's the actual product and hitting
different audiences yeah like like we
were talking about genders
um ethnicities age groups you know like
a milk audience pretty much caps it like
31 32 years old you know it's like
probably the oldest you know
um so you know how do I get the 32 to 50
year old to drink you know or 60 year
olds yeah and what about prime what do
you guys think about that
um someone asked me this morning
actually do you think those numbers are
real I think so like I think you gotta
remember one thing
Prime
one thing I do hate is when people
compare us to prime which happens
sometimes on social media I don't even
know why I read social media but on
social media like you know oh right
Prime's doing 250 million like show us
your numbers like nah ours is not that
you know like but we're also in 16
states only and but but I do believe
that Prime's doing the
um
that because not only
are they available in all states but
they're also absolutely massive in the
UK like KSI like is he a sleeper like in
terms of for Americans like he's he's
that guy I don't think people know how
big KSI is in the UK like he's I I mean
he's like he's like borderline royalty
out there like they love KSI out out in
the UK so so you got that strategic
partner
in Europe then you have Logan here and
then like Logan's genius marketing right
it's like there's not a place where he's
not holding up the bottle and making
sure it's the bottles getting as many
Impressions but also like you know I've
got a lot of all my friends you know I
was telling you before we even got
started like all my boys back on like my
best friends are we have there's a group
of 10 of us from high school 20
something years later we're all still
best friends most of them have kids
whenever their account they're coming
over at a Super Bowl party all the kids
Uncle John do you have Prime you know
dads are drinking happy Dad but Uncle
John yeah Prime and they Logan always
sends me cases to my house so I'm always
like giving the kids Prime and now they
want to come back we want to go to Uncle
John's house he has Prime these are kids
between eight eight and thirteen years
old yeah and is it like just basically
replacing Gatorade for them I think so
like like you know you and I probably
grew up and it was like the Michael
Jordan commercials and Gatorade and
everyone Powerade came you kind of like
that I think it's it's it's it's it's
what you just said I think it's Gatorade
combined with Michael Jordan because
Michael Jordan was cool to wear Michael
Jordan because of Michael Jordan because
Michael Jordan was so cool to kids back
then I think that's what Logan is Logan
is really cool to kids these days so he
really appeals to the 8 to 13 to you
know teens you know teens of all ages
you know people they love looking
obviously a lot of people hate Logan and
Jake you know but but you know but also
during the world of
Combat Sports there's you're supposed to
have people who hate you that's that's
why people are buying newspaper views
and they're making gazillions of dollars
with the Pay-Per-View so yeah but kids
love
Logan Paul kids love Jake Paul I know
because I see myself with all my friends
kids so that's why I think those numbers
are real and I think
I think like I think this is why maybe
their second full year too like I think
they're about as old as I remember I
think we're around the same age just
happy that maybe started a little bit
later but
they're murdering it uh I want to talk
about a couple other things but um on
the like I'll call it the milk business
you also have as you mentioned other
podcasts you guys have other products I
know that you guys have talked about uh
doing some sort of jerky product you
guys are obviously still doing merch
I've heard numbers that are like mid
eight figures on the merch of the year
like this is like a big big business
what is the structure of this is this
like a bunch of different businesses and
H1 has kind of different partners and
Equity splits or whatever is there like
uh it all rolls up and there's kind of
like a holding company and people would
think that they're almost like a
conglomerate like when you put on like
the business hat how do you think about
the way you all have built this and some
of it may be intentional some of it you
know sometimes you're just moving so
fast that like oh my god dude it's a
complete mess we got to fix it right but
like is it comparable to the
conglomerates of like yesteryear that
people would be familiar with in like
public companies or uh or even private
conglomerates or is it look different
from that
well um I think it's it's so I'll break
down the entire structure
um
there's there's three companies
um there's happy Dad
LLC the beverage consumer goods food
product
I'm gonna get to that and the kind of
the real Vision behind the direction
we're happy that's going there's full
send which is milk full sand
uh content house
but also uh merch um
those uh eight figures that you've heard
has been underneath the full sand milk
umbrella and then there's shots podcast
Network which is my shot Formerly Known
the shot Studios became a podcast
Network during covid you know when we
had to pretty much shut down the studios
and couldn't really have production we
pivoted the whole business into
podcasting
um
and those three pretty much ran by Me My
Brother Sam and Kyle so Kyle's now a
partner in shots as well and um and
Steve will do it and um
so
let's go go backwards so shots is just
the network shots is got the
relationships with all the platforms
shots is
um pretty much 14 years of me doing
YouTube
um so there's shots then there's full
send which which is really the merch
teams from Full sent golf Olson full net
Fitness all the different collabs full
send does and then even powering happy
Dad merch
but then there's happy Dad the way we
see happy Dad is um
you know it's not the same as
like like we don't see ourselves as like
the next Budweiser
um
definitely not the next truly a white
claw uh I think it's much bigger than
that I see it as the next PepsiCo is
what I see it like I but I want to model
the happy Dad company I think of the
Pepsi code model Pepsi owns Pepsi and
all the different Pepsi products
Mountain Dew different variations of
Pepsi Pepsi also owns Frito-Lay
uh Pepsi also owns Gatorade
Pepsi owns a bunch of different water
companies including Aquafina so they're
in the beverage and then they're in the
you know consumer goods product World up
until recently Pepsi owned Taco Bell
Pizza Hut KFC Long John Silver's
um and that's kind of the model with
happy Dad is you know we have happy Dad
happy dad's the number one
priority when it comes to consumer goods
but what more can happy that do we have
these teams that are walking through
these stores they're merchandising
they're building these displays they're
developing relationship with store
owners store managers buyers everybody
you know so while we're doing that we
have our own staff that's internal we
didn't subcontract that we don't use a
third party distributor for this we use
third-party Distributors to distribute
the alcohol but not to go actually build
the relationships we own those
relationships they're happy that
employees they have happydad.com emails
so while we're doing that what more can
we do
um that's where the idea of beef jerky
came in uh it was presented to me about
a year ago
um just somebody just cold emailed me
and just said hey like got a beef jerky
company would like would love to
see if there's something we can do
together
I'm I live in Orange County we're in
Orange County and I say hey stop by the
office let me give it a try bring some
samples try it out I was like wow this
is really good
um
you know shout out to this guy but um
Ahmad but um The Branding wasn't there
though I was like listen like I don't
think anyone's gonna buy that but but
you've done the most hardest part you've
made a great product let me help you
with the branding let me I'll come up
with something and let me help you with
the distribution
and um and that's what we did we
rebranded it uh during the time we
bought a bunch of board Apes so we said
all right so we have four Apes why don't
we do each one of the Apes will be a
different flavor call it beef jerky
board jerky and um and use our guys who
are going into the 7-Elevens Kroger's
independent stores wherever and say hey
while we have happy that we actually
have this other product as well and it's
doing this what you know doing really
great on socials we're we're doing this
sales wise we're doing this whatever you
know um their spill is in um and getting
that into stores and that's kind of like
going back to the Pepsi models all right
Pepsi has Pepsi and probably Pepsi is
the number one driver of Revenue
for the company is the Pepsi product but
Pepsi also has Frito-Lay what's our
Frito-Lay be beef jerky maybe down the
road there'll be other products maybe we
do get into
non-alcohol or other alcohol you know
we're getting to these liquor stores
maybe there's a spirit maybe you know
more but right now happy Dad has a lot
of work to do and then there's you know
our first food product that we'll be
Distributing and as you do this how much
of it will be you guys ideating the
actual products versus like somebody
brings to you and you're like hey you
already you know you nailed the product
but we can help with The Branding and
distribution and more so there's
probably a lot of people who are
listening who may have products this is
something you guys are actively seeking
and saying hey look if you got them come
show them to us or yeah we're always you
know I I you know what's crazy and and I
know my emails are going to blow up
before I say this but I read every
single email that's sent to me yeah
every single email I'll read it
um so there's other guys you know they
pitched us on ATM machines you know and
doing ATM machines and my first things
that's not food what's that have to do
with us but now I was like wait a minute
same place we're in a lot of bars you
know like
we could one of what if we made happy
that what if you skinned it as a happy
Dad ATM machine and now it's another
point of sale item inside that bar right
because maybe someone didn't know happy
that is available there and they went to
or their Jack and Coke but they need to
go get cash from the ATM machine they
see happy that logo there they come back
hey you guys have happy to hear oh yeah
we do yeah like you know they're just
not you know because people aren't we're
less than two years old they're not
programmed to go to the bar and think to
order happy Dad yet so how do we program
point of sale items well point of sale
we've got coasters that we make
available to all the different bars and
other on-premise locations we have neon
signs available upon request
um
we have napkins we give the staff all
the different merch but like maybe the
ATM machine is like that's a pretty big
piece of real estate inside that of that
location so so you know I'm always
looking at different things people send
um we will we'll uh we'll come up with
ideas ourselves
um you know many of the like the
flavor idea of happy mom or it's another
one that we're coming out with early
April with a very big partner
um
um it's gonna be a big surprise but a
big partner first week of April and then
um
you know so those are all like the
flavors and the ideas that the
Partnerships were all stuff that came in
internally but then people pitched so I
would say it's like 50 50. it's whatever
whatever makes sense We're not gonna
just do anything uh you know we do get
pitched a lot of dumb stuff as well you
know but you know but but if it makes
sense and it's something that we could
be helpful and doesn't distract us from
what we're currently doing we'll do it I
want to talk about Steve
um I don't really I'm not as familiar
with all the controversy but it sounds
like from a couple videos I've seen
recently he's not allowed in the YouTube
videos yeah or uh they get they'll get
taken down like I guess kind of what's
happened there and especially for our
audience who uh they're not going to be
up on the latest you know kind of
details of Nell can do in the content
like how would you describe Steve as
part of the group and then it almost
seems like he's kind of been banished
off of YouTube yeah well it's part of
the group part of the group it's very
simple Steve is a partner in everything
we do
um Steve is
a very close friend I would even say to
me a brother
um and
um you know I mean he's part of our
group and pretty much will be part of
our group the rest of our lives so so
he's he's part of us um and that'll you
know with or without whatever platform
that that's never going to change but
um
you know it's very unclear so when I was
going back and we were talking about the
Elon thing that Monday when we met when
we were supposed to get with Elon when
we landed we were told that Steve's
channel was
permanently banned and it just kind of
sold sucked a soul out of all of us
um when that happened and um do you like
tell Elon like yo Steve will do his
channel got banned and then he's like
Steve will do what yeah well no no
because at the same time Elon had also
said um
that um I guess someone had
Steve loves Elon to this day if you go
down his Twitter he's retweeting every
single thing Elon says okay and there
was one time he made just this joke
video when Bitcoin had crashed and you
know it came out that like Elon sold all
this Bitcoin and Bitcoin crashed and
Steve like lost a lot of money so he
made an anti-elon video Once that's a
joke you know the problem with the the
biggest problem Steve will do it has and
I think this is what's led to Steve's
termination of his YouTube is um people
can't tell that he's joking like they
can't tell his jokes you know what I
mean like I don't know if this is the
best analogy but I use this analogy once
I was like it's like
it's like this is like a woman like like
if you see a like a teacher like out
there she's
dressing not like a teacher but like
maybe like you know she looks like she's
like an exotic dancer and you're like
dude why is she dressed like that she's
a teacher she's not supposed to dress
like that but then like if you see a
girl that you know she you know she
works at it
tootsies and she's dressed the same way
that teacher was she's like no that's
fine she's she's a stripper you know
like and I think that's the same thing
with Steve is like people don't know
that he's a comedian so when he says
things people are just like hit so off
guard it's like yo why do you say that
it's like he's a comedian Steve is a
funny funny guy so if you're not
watching all those content you don't get
it so if you're just watching a clip
you're gonna be offended because he will
say some stuff but just be offensive if
it's just some random person on the
street but if you know a comedian said
it then maybe it'd be fine but if Theo
Von says that are if Tim Dylan says that
our Dave Chappelle says it or you know
you know any any stand-up comedian says
it it's like oh no no he's a stand-up
comedian he says that kind of [__] yeah
ah okay okay damn I got his [__] in
the dark you know but no one really
knows Steve is that it's like who is he
he's like oh he's some kid from Florida
that blew up on the Internet yeah oh and
he said what you know and I think that's
what's led to
people say it was because of gambling uh
maybe that's the reason I was used to
um terminate it
um but I don't think that's why I think
it's because people who are taking some
of the things that he said was offensive
because they don't know that he's
actually joking because if if a person
who has a Netflix special stand-up
comedian would say the same thing Steve
said people would be laughing about it
and sharing it so I think that's kind of
what happened with Steve but
it's a blessing in disguise because
after that he did a deal with Rumble and
he's got a you know I know it's very
early with Rumble but you know he's like
a priority to the CEO Chris he's like
always taking care of Steve they've
become good friends
um you know rumble's numbers have been
through the roof ever since then uh
Steve also launched a Audio Only podcast
as well with the video on Rumble
something very unique and it's like
helped his number no helped him develop
a new audience on on Spotify that's like
you know that's now introduces Steve
will do it world now it does hurt not
being a
allowed on YouTube uh he's launching a
Snapchat show you know um obviously with
Twitter he's he's good you know so yeah
um so he can't even be in the videos for
like the full send podcast that's crazy
yeah if he's if you guys like have him
his voice like just put him off to the
corner and not put him on video
it's just it it had we've thought about
it we thought about putting them you
know maybe make putting on a mask you
know yeah put him in a costume you know
we've thought of all all that I can only
imagine what you guys have thought of
yeah yeah we thought of it all maybe
he's uh you know maybe he's a DJ
competitor to marshmallow you know it's
like just becomes as the official DJ of
milk but no one knows who it is
um we've thought of it all
um and we might do that so hopefully no
from YouTube's made it this far into
this episode but
um
now the the truth is that's all joking
aside is the truth is I think life goes
on and I think it's time for him to
focus on other things people love Steve
when he's still his channel was
terminated in August so it's been what
six seven months and
um when he shows up for meetups same
same amount of crowd you know
um you know nothing's really changed
other than not having YouTube but like
you know with happy Dad he's just as
important as a partner to us
um you know
it's tough for me to say
I don't I don't agree that he can't be
in videos you know so it's just tough
for me to like kind of go down that
rabbit hole so I just kind of stay mute
because
um the people I've talked to at YouTube
about it
um
I I don't want to say who or what what
department or anything but they've all
like pretty much like said the same
thing to me it's like we don't agree
either like like it's it's like a deeper
group within there it seems weird like I
understand taking down the channel right
like again I don't agree with it based
on what I understand you're saying or
whatever but like okay uh but to then
say like you basically ban the person
from YouTube where like they can't even
appear on anyone else's yeah Channel
I feel like that's being bullied because
if they said you know and I think
they're just bullying creators when
they're saying that because
Andrew Tate was banned from YouTube as
well right
but he's on Piers Morgan's channel on
peers so Pierce is okay because he's
Pierce Morgan he's part of a massive
network but we're just some small
creators we don't you know like
you need that massive Network because
they probably spend x amount of dollars
with this other department so you can't
piss them off by deleting Piers Morgan's
you know chat Channel or or video
but you don't really need anything from
us you know so
different we're threatened you know I
mean but but you know if like let's just
say going back to Andrew Tate was
probably you know what the most hated
person on the internet might be the most
banned person on the internet
um
but if Andrew Tate went on Good Morning
America that'd be okay for them to air
it on their Channel you go on Good
Morning America 10 times I Gotta Give
ABC a hard time you know um
but Steve will do it comes on the full
send podcast hey you're going to be
terminated sounds like Steve will do it
should go on Good Morning America
very true right yeah we got it actually
he was joking about that he was like
maybe um
he's like you know what's funny is uh
he's like maybe I should go on a Mr
Beast video he's like you think you can
make that happen let's see if like they
take down Mr Beast oh that's actually a
genius idea like let's see I doubt they
would take down Mr Beast I don't think
that they would do that he said that he
said that a few weeks ago we were in
Arizona it's like we're talking about
that we're like maybe we should put you
in a Mr Beast video yeah but but yeah
it's sad it's sad because
um listen I would be the first to admit
if we did something wrong
and and and nelk has done the world of
now all everyone has done some dumb
things here and there but does it
nothing
his nothing that's led to the
consequence of being permanently banned
on the biggest social network in the
world the second biggest website in the
world without any type of warning there
was no warning no nothing so that one
like that's why it just kind of sucks
it's like this Steve has done listen
Steve has done a lot of dumb things a
lot of time publicly some
behind the scenes a lot and any time
I've called them I said Steve I wouldn't
do that or I wouldn't he stops you know
I mean like he stops he's he's moving a
million miles an hour anytime I have
colors he's 24. yeah anytime I've called
him or his mom's called them or Sam or
Kyle anyone's that say hey Steve and
explain logically not Steve stop hey
Steve don't do this because this this
this and that ah [__] I didn't think of
it like that John you're so right you
know or his mom or something a 24 year
old kid and everything you do basically
is on the internet
I can't I can't I can't imagine I can't
I wasn't yeah there was no I don't even
know come on I mean was YouTube even a
thing when I was 24 I don't know
um but um but yeah so that's why to me
it was like Steve is a very logical
smart guy he's not dumb at all he's
moving a million miles an hour but if
someone slows him down and explains
things to him he stops I know I know
this I talked to his mom and I are very
close and we talk five six days a week
you know and where everyone's always in
the you know we got this pretty much
this board of directors around Steve to
always protect them but he listens he's
not he's not unmanageable or anything
like that and that's the one thing he
never got from YouTube it was a phone
call hey we don't like this
now could you please not do this that
never happened it just was hey
permanently ban
no appeal no nothing
sorry do you think it changes uh with uh
Susan leaving a CEO and uh this guy Neil
coming in or do you think that it's kind
of below CEO level I don't think I don't
think it's a YouTube level I think it
was a Google level I don't think it was
a YouTube because everyone that I've
talked to at YouTube it's like dude we
love this we don't agree with this
everyone I've talked to YouTube I've
never talked to Susan about it but
everyone else I've talked to from you
know high up down yeah
you know like they've not I don't know I
don't know might not even be a YouTube
thing it might even be a third party
contractor that they you know contracted
policies out to you know everyone does
that Twitter yeah I know that I know
damn well Twitter did that Elon got rid
of them all of them but Twitter was
doing that it wasn't on Twitter we had
our YouTube channel deleted one time uh
we were on a live stream and we got done
and it was deleted and thank God I had
Twitter because I went on Twitter and
honestly you know having a field day
being like what the hell just happened
and it took a while but I had numerous
YouTube employees DM me and be like hey
send me the information and I'll you
know try to navigate internally
um and it turns out that uh the official
communication was like uh there was a
mistake made chance reinstated you're
fine
um
but the unofficial stuff was like one
person hit the delete button right and
like I think to me it was like I don't
know who the person was I didn't want to
know right it's just like look just got
to channel back move on whatever
um I was like man one one employee can
do that yeah right that's what I mean
and like and that's what happened to
Steve that's what happened to Steve you
know I don't know don't know it was a
contractor out you know they contracted
a firm out of and you know in middle of
nowhere I don't know I don't know yeah I
don't know but we'll never know but what
I tell Steve is maybe things change
maybe there could be reinstatement but
in the meantime build this relationship
with you have with Rumble you know I
know it's not YouTube but
they take care of you and they're
they're growing as well but then also
you've got everything else you know you
have so much more and when we walk the
streets with Steve just as many people
going losing their minds when they see
Steve in the streets today as they were
a year ago so nothing's really changed
as far as his relevancy goes
when you think of
full send milk kind of the whole thing
today right those three companies Etc
how big can this get like is this a
thing where the aspiration is we want to
build a billion dollar business we want
to build a 10 billion 100 billion is it
like we think we can build this and you
know some large corporation will come in
and buy us out like what kind of when
you guys sit around in private you think
about like imagine if how big are the
dreams or aspirations
um you know one thing I've never ever
done is build anything in hopes of
selling so I've always wanted every
business including shots over shots is
14 years old now happy dad's about two
years old full sun milk I only joined
about almost three years ago now but it
was you know it's about 10 years old
seven years old without me
um
my first focus is make it a successful
profitable business treat this like
we're never selling and we're just going
to be a profitable business we're
growing we're innovating you know um
we're monetizing you know monetization
you know monetization leads to being
able to innovate and we could create you
know happy Dad was self-funded at the
very beginning
um to this day we haven't really brought
on any large investors and um so
you know we make all decisions you know
happy Mom I don't have to go get someone
so's approval we decided
my brother and I decided ran it by
Stephen Kyle they loved it that's it
that's happening yeah um and that's
always been the philosophy now how big
it could become you know because we do
have shareholders so I sometimes have to
answer that question is I think in each
one of each one of those business itself
is a several hundred million if not
billion dollar company
um
and then happy that the different
businesses within happy debt I think I
think happy dad's a multi-billion dollar
man I think happy dad's I think you're
not thinking big enough yeah I think no
I think happy Dad could easily be ten
plus billion 10 plus bill I think happy
that's gonna have number of billion
dollar companies within it right I think
board jerky itself is a billion dollar
company I think someone will call them I
saw the rock
um with taramana tequila I'm gonna mess
up the numbers but Casa Migos uh I think
when they sold somebody said they were
doing like 180 000 cases or that they
had done 180 000 I think for a billion
and The Rock has now sold a million
cases no right so again maybe the
numbers are you know not exactly the
same from multiple bases uh price points
could be different profitability could
be different the economic environment is
different like there's a whole bunch of
uh kind of asterisks alongside that but
like terraman is probably a
multi-billion dollar uh business yeah
right for that audience uh size and
engagement I feel like not only do you
guys have a very large audience a very
engaged audience but you also have a
really long Runway right like everyone
loves the rock he's one of the most
recognizable people in the world he's
older yeah yeah right and so if you
think over the next you know 10 15 years
all those 21 to 28 29 year olds they're
eventually going to become 30 and 40
year olds yeah we you know
you know and happy that we also have
Partners outside now so Drewsky became a
partner recently sugar Shawn O'Malley
became a partner recently
um there's a partner that's coming out
April 1st I can't say who
but I'm gonna [__] I'm gonna show you
and I just want you to see your reaction
all right and then we'll all right but I
can't say you can't say I'm just gonna
show you oh no
oh
he actually came out with the flavor
idea himself too
not yet
[Laughter]
yeah that's a grand slam he came out
with the flavor and the pack of course
of course yeah
like that's a grand slam yeah so that's
so he's become a partner in the company
and um and we're launching a our first
uh
well I don't want to say our first
um our first collab our first collab was
actually in my opinion this our board a
banana flavor
um that was our first collab but this
will be our second clap you would say
um but yeah that's coming out so so
that's you know so when now when I'm
thinking happy Dad I'm like all right I
got we got these other partners and by
the way he hits a different market like
he's and that was his approach to us he
came up and said hey what are you doing
within the black community it's like
trying to figure it out he's like let me
run that for you let me let me handle
that part for you know I was like a
pretty good person to do it yeah so I
was like
I'd love to have you you know Mr Mrs you
know I'm not gonna I guess I've said him
so yeah we know it's a mister but um
but yeah yeah let's let's do it so this
was about
maybe a year ago this time it's been a
year partnership in the works and we're
launching it April 1st
so
um but yeah so going back to it is like
so shots in my opinion several hundred
million dollars I mean it's right now
it's currently actually the biggest
podcast Network on YouTube shots shots
podcast network is
um full send
is and can be the next bar stool Sports
in my opinion
um you know uh it's gonna be a lot of
work don't wanna ever take away anything
from fortnite 20 plus years of grinding
so it's not like an overnight thing but
in the long run it could be its own
network for sports content male and
female focused content both
um you know um comedy what not and then
and then there's happy Dad which happy
that the beverage itself to me is
Billion Dollar Plus is coming but then
Happy dad's gonna have these other
brands within it that'll also you know
or jerky in my opinion could be a
billion dollar plus company itself so so
that's why it's like multiple multiple
ones but all three are very different
too yeah but they all complement each
other you know the full send brand and
everything full Sim brings to the table
helps happy Dad yeah shots podcast
Network helps bring on podcasts and you
have like the pivot podcast where every
episode they're drinking happy to add
and we're partners with them now and you
know other partner other podcasts that
we're gonna bring underneath the
partnership that we're gonna be drinking
happy Dad in every single episode or
even some of the collabs
that we're gonna do we're gonna do a
pivot podcast happy Dad collab yeah
um so you know so they all they all all
these companies talk they all they all
talk yeah it's very smart yeah where can
we send people to find you if they want
to just kind of pay attention as you
guys continue or before they want to
reach out
um don't give your email yeah they they
find my my email's too easy I gotta make
it more complicated
um
no I mean my socials you know I'm just
at John
everywhere Twitter Instagram Snapchat I
have at John
um I don't use tick tock much but
whatever time well every so often I'm on
at John there I'm at John on YouTube so
just John everywhere but uh that's my
personal but I think if you really want
to follow and see everything just follow
Our Brands follow happy Dad on us on
socials board jerky uh shots milk boys
you know those are I think more
entertaining my personal ones and I'm
sorry I'm so focused on helping other
people with their social strategies I
forget about myself so I don't really
know what I'm doing I just throw up
random stuff on my socials yeah I think
you're doing just fine yeah awesome
thank you so much for doing this I
always enjoyed talking Angela and yeah I
don't think people quite understand just
the uh the size of what you guys have
built and how fast some of the stuff's
growing so it's cool to talk to you and
yeah hopefully it'll inspire a lot of
other people to uh that's that's why I
do these podcasts man I want I want
every once in a while whenever I do
these someone messages me that they were
inspired or they're doing this or that I
really you know I don't like doing all a
lot of these but I do them because I
just know that there's people out there
who just want to get up and get off
their ass and do it whether launch your
own podcast start your own company
design your own merch whatever it is you
know like just do it because that's
that's been the secret to us is like you
know when we want to do something we do
it and um we don't like I've said before
and I'm gonna say forever we don't burn
Bridges we're always thinking long term
and um and you know and and we have fun
you know we do everything we do
everything that we do is just fun so
that's what I'm hoping that anyone who's
listening to this will just get up and
just do it I love it all right thank you
so much